صداقه الصين لروسيا لا حدود لها وفق قول
بكين وتدرس هنا جديا في الوقت الراهن دعم
صديقتها في الحرب عبر ارسال المعدات
والاسلحه للقوات الروسيه وفق ما كشفته
صحيفه تيليجراف البريطانيه وهذا القرار
يمكن ان يرجح كافه الحرب لصالح روسيا كما
انه قد يمكن المصنعين الصينيين من اختبار
وتقييم اسلحتهم بشكل حاسم وواقعي لتاكيد
من فعاليتها في اي صراع مستقبلي كغزو
تايوان مثلا الصين لديها الكثير لتقدمه
لروسيا لا سيما في مجال الصواريخ والاسلحه
الموجهه رغم ان الامدادات الاساسيه مثل
قذائف المدفعيه والطائرات من دون طيار من
المرجح ايضا ان تكون على راس قائمه
الامدادات لروسيا وبعد الاطلاع مشاهدينا
على بيانات تابعه للجمارك الروسيه تم
بالفعل شحن المعدات الملاحيه وقطع غيار
المقاتلات النفاثه وتكنولوجيا التش غيرها
من المعدات العسكريه من الصين الى روسيا
تقول هنا صحيفه الامريكيه في المقابل على
مدار سنوات اشترت بكين منتجات روسيه الصنع
وصنعت نسخا منها خاصه بها وقد اصبحت شركات
الاسلحه والدفاع الصينيه من بين اكبر
الشركات في العالم اكثر من ذلك بدات الصين
عام 2013 دمج الذكاء الصناعي في عمليه صنع
القرار بحلول عام 2035
وشرعت ببناء وشرعت ببناء اسطول من السفن
الحربيه مع اكثر من اثنتي عشره طراد
ومدمره وحامله طائرات وتقوم بكين الان
ايضا ببناء اسطول من المقاتلات الشبحيه
شبيهه بالانواع التي يمتلكها الغرب حاليا
[موسيقى]